The Joe Rogan Experience I know you
retired from football and um you're
still in the prime of your life did you
retire because of injuries did you
decide that you had you had enough like
yeah it was a combination of all that so
I had I had uh double hip surgeries I
tore the labrums off the bone oh Jesus
um I've been my NFL like the injuries I
had while I was in the NFL were just out
of control man uh 2013 I bruised my
spinal cord I was paralyzed
for three hours and then I played two
weeks later oh my God and I played for
12. it was miserable every time I got
touched my arms would go numb like and
I'm a defensive lineman so my head's
getting hit every play
holy [__] what was the play that made
your spine get bruised so I was playing
like on the end of the line on the right
side and I was playing a cut block
somebody try to cut my legs out so I'm
playing like sprawled out to play the
cut block and then the fullback hit me
on top of the head oh and it did I was
awake it didn't knock me out it just
like it felt like uh you know when
you're sitting on a [__] for too long
get up yes exactly how my whole body
felt from the nose down oh my God you
must have been terrified I was scared
but then when I started when I could
feel them like touching my toes
um like a couple hours after it happened
I was in the hospital that's when I just
started making jokes and stuff because I
knew I was something in my head just
said you're gonna be fine
like I just had a feeling I had no
choice when I was a young kid 22 years
old 23 years old wow and then uh 12
weeks later I was playing good football
still somehow 12 weeks later
I had a seizure
like a bad seizure and almost killed me
I had to go I was in a coma for 36 hours
so what
what did the seizure come out of a play
or did it no it's because I wasn't
getting fresh blood to my brain because
there was a bruise on that spinal right
at the base of my brain stem
and it never healed I didn't let it heal
two weeks isn't going to heal a bruise
you know holy [__] it never healed so I
wasn't getting fresh blood in my brain
so I was running on just like pure
adrenaline and how did they clear you to
play two weeks later they told me it was
a stinger
oh God he said it's just a stinger
you're fine well they said well you know
when you uh have a big warehouse and you
flip the lights off they come right off
but when you turn them on it takes a
while for them to come back on that's
what they told me happened they're
comparing you to a warehouse yeah you're
like hey [__] I'm a human that's
when I realized man I was like they
don't care about us no no there's
another guy waiting to take your spot
that's what's so crazy and that's why
you have to play yeah that's why guys
play hurt and played yeah banged up um
so did you how much time did you get to
train before you went and played two
weeks later like how much I just went
straight into practice so the next week
wow right the next week so one week
after you're paralyzed you're in
practice Yeah so they tried to keep me
in the hospital after that after like
after the game and I was like when's the
plane leaving and they were like they're
getting ready to go to the plane right
now it's a preseason game and I was like
okay well I'm getting on that plane then
so I had him take me from the hospital
to the plane so the doctors wanted you
in the hospital yeah doctors wanted me
to stay but the team doctors were like
you're good we can go
Steve doctors are savages oh my god well
they did the x-rays and the MRIs right
away you know and right so that like we
went straight to the the ER I was on a
on a stretcher you know into an
ambulance they'd bring the ambulance on
the field I couldn't move
I was just stuck in the ground it was
like
it was like I was melted you know it
couldn't move at all every all my
muscles were just it was the weirdest
feeling man but it like I said it
started I was feeling better but I think
I just tricked my brain into thinking
like
I was in survival mode I've been in
survival mode since the day I came out
of the womb man I just
like always surviving you know just
trying to survive through whatever it is
that's going on it's like I disassociate
from it and
great skill to have if you want to play
professional football right well I don't
know if you saw what Deion Sanders just
said about um what he's looking for in a
quarterback he wants two parent home
um it's a two-parent home a 3.5 GPA and
he went to the complete opposite for a
defensive lineman really yeah he's like
I want
it's either football or prison pretty
much type of [__]
but if you think about the position and
you think about what you guys have to do
it kind of makes sense oh you have to be
[__] barbaric yeah it is a [__]
war in there you got two I mean the way
that the size of these offensive linemen
now I mean they're [__] 350 pounds
and there's two of them and they're
trying to move you every [__] play oh
my God and you better
if you play [__] you're gonna get
[__] that's what I used to that's what
I always say
you go out there playing [__] you're
gonna get [__] that's just the way it
goes what is the average lifetime of a
career like in the NFL from two and a
half years wow because at that third
year you get vested
so vested means you get pension and uh
all the benefits that come with that and
most guys don't get there and most guys
don't get there
you know we we talk about it with
fighting all the time that a a real
elite athlete in his prime has like nine
years you got like that's that's the
consensus is there's like nine years at
Peak Performance and then it's just too
much
the wheels fall off the injuries stack
up you know the the timing train and
then sometimes it's enthusiasm too guys
lose that that fire that made him a
Savage in the beginning but football's
even worse
I mean it's even shorter time well it's
shorter but your earnings right your
your earnings you don't get to that
you're on a rookie contract for your
first four years so you get drafted and
you're on that rookie contract you make
pretty much slotted out the money you
don't if you're not a top 10 pick in the
in the draft and you're not really
making life-changing money you know
um I have seven dollars when I got
drafted though I didn't even have a bank
account
and I'm [__] that was just a
[__] poor ass kid from Ohio
I went to Cincinnati and
I lived with Travis and Jason Kelsey
we all lived in the same house
um I don't know if you know those guys
are but uh Travis is like best tight end
in the history of the NFL now Jason's
gonna be the best center of both Hall of
Famers just played against each other in
the Super Bowl
and then our quarterback went up to
Canada won two gray cups so we got four
Super Bowls and two great cups
in that house and we were [__] ups
we were [__] idiots
but again don't you kind of want that
from I want football players to be a
little reckless you have to be yeah same
with Fighters I don't want a [__] Boy
Scout exactly when Jon Jones kept
getting into trouble and people like you
believe what Jon Jones did I'm like
Jon Jones is a wild [__] that's
why he's the greatest of all time you
need an element of psycho you have to be
[__] up you have to be [__] up you
do and it's just the way it goes you got
to be a little [__] up to do it it's
is that true with all of them is that
true like you've been around the grades
you've been around some amazing players
like is that true with all of them no no
it's all most d-linemen interior
defensive lineman though they're [__]
up they are they're just [__]
different like Aaron Donald is a
different [__] he's I mean he's
gonna go down to the best defense attack
would ever do it but he's [__] wild
like he's crazy do you think he tries to
kill people out there he came in with
that or I think that also developed over
the course of his career I think it
develops over your life right I don't
know his life story or anything but most
of us have been through some [__] right
you know and it's just you can kind of
see it when you meet a guy he's just
[__] different right yeah and I when
you meet then you meet I have like
Peyton Manning good friend of mine now
you know we we were teammates for four
years one won a Super Bowl together
um and he still lives in Denver so we
see each other all the time but like
Peyton was like complete opposite like
he'd [__]
he like controlled the room everything
he did was like dialed in it was so
dialed and so professional like he came
to work like dressed professionally
right defensive lineman we're coming in
[__] slides and [__] shorts and
t-shirts and [__] right
he'd show up [__] buttoned up with a
suitcase or with a briefcase you know
and went right to the film room we're
going [__] to the weight room right
that's where we're going so it was just
a different vibe man and then like
DeMarcus Ware [__] ultimate like such
a professional everything about him was
professional but the great d-linemen
that are interior guys
they're usually [__] up John Randall
you've heard of him yes this guy [__]
slept on a [__] dirt floor growing up
Jesus you think he's not a little [__]
up yeah
and then there's the sport itself which
I mean just the amount of impacts you
guys are taking on regularly every day
when it came to to stop to be stopping
with the NFL like when I was like I'm
done
um I played eight years in Denver which
was awesome
um and then I dislocated my elbow bad
going into a contract here in 2019. I
was having my best season in my career
year eight balling out about to get
another payday
and uh it was like a dead play so the
whistle didn't get blown couple guys
jumped off sides and the whistle gets
blown halfway through the play so half
the half the [__] field is moving at
full speed and half the fields not and
it's like fourth and inches play so I
try to make the [__] tackle and I
like slow up and I end up slipping and
falling and I'm going to get up in our
330 pound nose tackle goes to like he's
like running straight at me and his
[__] Shin hits me right in the elbow
and it goes to the ground oh dislocated
all the way to the [__] ground I
[__] dude I was I've never been in so
much pain
it hurts so [__] it made me want to
throw up I was throwing up in my mouth
because I was grabbing at it and trying
to put it back in oh because I in 2016 I
did that with my right elbow it came out
I put it right back in and just kept
going
I mean that's the [__] the [__] your
fingers get popped out all the time you
just put them in and go like there's no
time to [__] around
and I was trying to get it to go in and
I could just feel it grinding on the
bone grinding against each other and it
was like making me [__] ill then they
took me and they took me in the locker
room and I was [__] pissed because I
knew it was going to cost me a bunch of
money that elbow deal is gonna cost me
if I knew it it probably cost me 20
million oh
[__] pissed my own teammate he didn't
mean to him it's nice yeah but it was
like on a dead [__] play I was losing
my [__] I [__] slammed my helmet I
was like these [__] like I was
blaming the ref so blaming everybody
okay [__] raps I'm gonna sue the
[__] refs
my turn all right you know yeah think
and here's the other thing before games
I was taking micro doses so I'm
microdosed and I might like taking
mushrooms yes yeah yeah before games so
I'm taking mushrooms the Viking in you
yeah I'm [__] taking mushrooms and
[__] Adderall wow oh my God before I
play combination yeah what is that like
mushrooms and Adderall dude the [__]
focus is out of control and I would just
like before games I would like I would
like get myself pissed off so I just
would start thinking about my childhood
like the [__] that I went through as a
kid whoa and they would [__] get me
in this rage mode now it was like this
crazy controlled rage
so Adderall mushrooms and childhood rage
yeah all together in a 280 pound Savage
well I was like 300 pounds then you know
oh my God I was like 20 pounds heavier
than I am now when I was playing
oh my God just [__] such a meathead
saying wild crazy [__] to quarterbacks I
told I told a guy I was gonna [__]
eat his kids oh my God
it was crazy
what did he say he did he didn't say
[__] he never talked I played against
this guy twice a year for eight years
and that was in year four that that
happened so four years straight he never
said another word to me oh my God he was
like this guy's so [__] sicko
once I got married and had kids and
stuff though I like I was like quoted on
saying [__] like that but I just that's
what you do man it's a [__] head game
I'm just a head game I'm trying to get
in his head yeah 100 yeah I always try
to explain that to people people Conor
McGregor is a [__] [__] the things
he says I'm like it's part of the game I
mean it's yeah I get it you don't want
to hear those things I get it I get it
but that that's legal and that works it
works it's it's strategy it's unsue Art
of War